south carolina
you from columbia columbia yup that's
where charlemagne started his radio
career right
yeah first shout out to man early on he
was in i don't know if that's where he
necessarily started
yeah i thank you from on like something
to south carolina or something like that
monk's corner
something yeah i think that's close to
something though charleston no it's
about charleston
maybe he was in charleston not not not
yeah yeah charleston
but yeah he most definitely was um he
got ties in columbia for sure
yeah yeah um i was just talking to
carter about
kind of like the carolinas in general
being they're such a
important part of of rappers careers
that we don't even acknowledge because
of all the radio stations that are in
both of those states
and it's almost like you can't really
find an artist
that it's really popped like without
having that region on lock yeah
yeah and it's crazy because like like
the carolinas there you know they'll go
crazy like
when like anybody else come but it's
like it's it's kind of weird like when
you from there i guess it's like that
everywhere
it's just like that everywhere yeah i
don't really use it as an excuse but
most definitely like
carolina's be one of the first places
where all the people come
and make their money though for sure
because they gonna they gonna book them
the promoters gonna book them and
people gonna show up and go crazy for
them 100 what do you
how do you compare north carolina versus
south carolina is it like what's the big
difference
if any um like north carolina a little
bit more kind of
advanced like we only got no nfl team
right
like the biggest y'all just claimed the
panthers because it's just carolina
panthers
yeah let's kill our pandas the owl the
street so that's all we got in it
only thing like columbia got is um like
the gamecocks like the ufc
yeah i remember seeing those hats as a
kid
and it would just say [ __ ] on it and
i'd be like yo
fam yeah what is going on what school is
this
yeah yeah i'd be at the lids and it'd be
a hat that just said cox on and i'd be
like bro what the [ __ ] oh this south
carolina gang cox
they should put the whole thing on there
that's so crazy um
it is